oui
[Musique]
l'hymne national japonais a retenti au
stade jean maréchal de
montigny-le-bretonneux une équipe
composée de joueurs de ligue 1 juste
reyel est venu disputer un match contre
l'équipe de france en tant que
représentant japonais nous voulons bien
figurer sur le terrain pour remporter ce
match et faire honneur à la sélection de
notre pays
pour moi le but aujourd'hui est de
gagner mais surtout de représenter
fièrement l'équipe japonaise
il faut être au top tous les jours cette
rencontre internationale est une
première pour la ville c'est très très
rare de les avoir c'est vrai en france
parce que le voyage déjà un fou qui se
déplace et on les a déjà eu il ya deux
trois ans et c'est vrai que c'est très
rare qui viennent mais c'est vraiment
exceptionnel de les avoir en français
pour voir ce spectacle près de 120
personnes ont fait le déplacement
je connais pas du tout le baseball et
c'est un sport que je trouve sympa à
découvrir donc ça change quand j'étais
au japon je joue au baseball
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment heureux de
voir un match de baseball
l'occasion pour les spectateurs de voir
également les joueurs locaux aujourd'hui
deux joueurs des cougars de montils
bretons ne sont présents le troisième
base daniel patry c'est le lanceur
antoine euros c'est très très important
pour nous aujourd'hui de pouvoir
développer le baseball encore plus à
montigny plaisir devant ses supporters
d'être devant un public aujourd'hui qui
est quand même nombreux donc c'est bien
pour le baseball français pour montigny
le bretonneux
le match s'est finalement terminée par
une victoire des japonais sur le score
de 22 à 0
montigny le bretonneux sera à nouveau
candidat pour accueillir une nouvelle
sélection nationale dans les prochaines
années